Damon - went from sweeping the floors of
a local barber shop and selling
newspapers to buy sneakers to launching
the careers of jay-z and Kanye West and
becoming one of the wealthiest men in
hip-hop - learned the hustle from the
example of his mother who died of an
asthma attack when he was 15 years old
he served the jay-z's former manager and
business partner at Rockefeller Records
and in 1999 he organized a tour for
jay-z which made 19 million dollars need
motivation watch the top 10 with the
lead nation
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend here's my take on
Damon Dash's top ten roast success vol 5
also if you want to know what Dame - and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below knowing the one
thing you have to really never do is
compare yourself to other people
absolutely that's the one thing you
can't do is judge the success to someone
else's
okay let's pick it off with rule number
one do what makes you happy it's all
about effort and what you can visualize
in your mind you know if you can't think
it can happen and if you don't have
confidence that it's going to happen it
ain't gonna happen
so if you doubt yourself like you know
our box or at least I used to
I'm not getting in the ring unless I
know I'm gonna win or else I already
lost and I look at everything I do like
that I'm winning and there is nothing
it's 100 percent everything is about
perspective and what you consider a win
you know some people think they're
winning because other people think
they're winning even though they don't
feel good about what they're doing
they're like oh you think I'm winning so
that must mean I'm winning but I feel
like that's not winning you know you
have to know what makes you happy what
you consider aware not everybody's win
is the same you know the same but people
like to fit in with a w's would not mean
I know what my w's are rule number two
be the boss the reason why people take
jobs is cuz they got to pay their bills
when you say be a boss to be independent
everybody should be an entrepreneur and
everyone has an apartment right you're
the boss in your apartment right no
matter what no matter how little it is
if it says whether it's a big house or a
little house that space right there you
have the boss that's what your business
is that's what your life is you create
the space so you can control it you
control your environment but you have to
art detect that you want to live in the
house build it you know I'm saying am I
gonna give it to you but once you get in
that house I don't care if the President
or whoever it is
anyway he walked in my house Obama you
still gotta listen to me in this house
people think is safe to have a job but
if somebody can find you how is that
safe period like you gotta be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you and if they do people like a
fire you don't be owning evil might be
supervisors so then it becomes like
political if there's no politics with
you in the boss it's my way or no way
out because I believe that you see that
at any point no matter how much you
contribute that whole thing can be taken
away at any particular time right so how
does somebody then go and just make that
shift to the same stuff they're doing
for somebody else do it for yourself
right if you got paid editor edit your
movie you a paid writer right it's home
magazine you know it's like the thing is
nobody ever gave me anything no one gave
me real no record deal I had to do it
myself so imagine if I were to waited
for a deal for jay-z there'd be no
II know Kanye there be no Lee Daniels
there be no Kevin Hart there'd be no
Rachel Roy none of that you know I'm
saying none of them any I had to build
all that like no one's gonna hire me to
direct you know I mean no one's about
hire me to be the CEO of a company I
made the company I'm the CEO of it
period rule number three
believe in yourself what I find there's
a lot of people are really insecure
about themselves they don't think there
is interesting as they are so many
people be so quick to make money of
other people's experience I mean you
know when you got your own like what's
the purpose of it there's no say that
again yeah and that's what I had to do
that's what you have to do are once we
started to believe in ourselves we just
work a little harder but you end up
reaping all the benefits on it on your
own terms and it feels 100% good and you
can touch all the people you own and it
makes the most sense rule number four
love the game I wanted to capitalize
capitalize off everything I thought I
was the best at so I thought I was the
best at dressing I didn't think I could
dance better than me so I thought new
hit records I knew I had the best
multiple authentic experiences so I know
I make the best movies and I just wanted
to do all those things but in hindsight
I just like to do cuz I like to do it's
fun I'm really creative you know what I
mean I just like to be artistic freely
and you know it's like I don't know I
just I just I just like don't I just
thought you know I think I just I'm
having so much fun and you know when you
get success relatively young it's like
you know get settled but then you gonna
get bored so you know I was a mogul when
I was in my 20s oh I was like I want to
go do fashion I want to go I want to run
around the world I wanted everything I
see or hear about I wanted to see it
personally I want to live it I want to
know what I want to touch it
rule number five invest in yourself so
looking back that how do you feel about
rockefeller today it doesn't same
attitude that I think it's a shame it
doesn't exist anymore
you know I think the way that it
dissolved was kind of selfish but I'm
not gonna get into that you know I'm
saying but it would have been nice to
see everybody doing well as opposed to
one person and that's the way I want it
Rockefeller I'm a you know I believe in
the circle of success where everybody
gets rich I don't want to make employees
I want to make bosses only enterprise
well it was you know but then it turned
out to be one person stayed rich and
everyone else had to work for him and
that's not how I
Rockefeller what I realized is I need to
make an invest in things that I could
pass to my family so I had to invest
more in myself as opposed to investing
in other people because not everybody
has the same idea idea idea a lot of
ideology as me you know I'm saying not
everybody you know looks at things the
same way so you know I should have
probably paid a little more attention
than making assets that I own as opposed
to making other people because my thing
was I was putting people in power so
that they could put us in power but
every time I put somebody in power they
would shut the door and they just wanted
all the power it's just human nature
it's how men are is the testosterone and
that's why I also surround myself more
with women because women don't tend to
be so jealous do you think that's more
of an exclusively male thing than
females on as the hungry when they get
in that position I think males are so
supremely insecure that they turn into
clowns rule number six don't cut corners
a lot of people would cheat and try to
cut corners but I don't consider that a
win you know what I'm saying like if I
know the game I'm playing and I sign on
to it that's the only way I want to win
at it I don't want to cheat to get dick
if then I didn't win at my game Bobby
actually lost yes you lost you
understand but you know I'm not gonna
play your game I only play my own
achieve me you don't fully believe in
your abilities in the first place yes
overcompensation fishing mood but then
that's like a different kind of way you
know you playing a different game rule
number seven dream bigger you know I
have bigger dreams than trying to be
getting a salary from some company you
know I need to own something and I need
legacy you know like the dashes are
gonna be they are I already know it
we're gonna be like the Kennedys and an
abandoned you know we're gonna be an
upstanding family yeah that's what I
wanted to be and that's what I mean but
that's what I'm saying I wanted it easy
for my kids and I want to easy for my
kids kids and that's all I'm doing right
now we're just making sure that the
company can run when I'm not around you
know I'm saying family and company
that's what that's what that's what you
know it has to be able to sustain rule
number eight don't operate out of fear
everybody says they want to be the boss
but people be standing
most people are scared to put up their
own money most people are scared to tell
people to work when they don't want to
most people are scared to even ask for
the money you know what I'm saying like
people actually people that are
uncomfortable about asking about their
own business like asking for change get
paid or what am I gonna get paid or
where's my money I have never felt
uncomfortable about asking for my bread
and I've never understood people that
were uncomfortable for asking for their
bread and I really don't understand
people that are offended by you asking
for your bread yeah you ask somebody for
their money and they're like what you
asking like I'm not supposed to ask for
my money am I supposed to ask about my
money like the money and the business
this promotion with asking about it
because it's business there should be no
fear you should never be ashamed to ask
for your change ever you know or to
scrutinise a bill rule number nine stay
ahead of the curve after my daughters
were born I shut down everything I was
doing I bested all my money into at
Rachel Roy and then I just opened up art
galleries where creative people could
come in coexist and make things happen
without compromise the quality of living
yeah so I opened up DD 172 which was a
10,000 square foot gallery and the most
expensive real estate in Manhattan and
Tribeca and you know I had people like
Mos Def and Jay Electronica and Wiz
Khalifa and currency and it just goes on
rock and roll the Black Keys you know
the Holy Ghost Erykah Badu all perform
and I had and in that television station
called creative control this was in 2009
I'm always added occur you want to know
the future just ask me and rule number
ten the last one before a very special
bonus clip is attack your bucket list we
have chapters in my life yes you know
the cool about the way I post thing is I
always have like an L bucket list you
know I'm saying and there'll be there's
a bunch of things that I want to do in
my life and eventually I know
we do so young I wanted the hustle I got
that off my bucket list quick you know
saying I wanted to be a music mogul off
my bucket list I wanted to be a fashion
mogul off my bucket list I wanted to
sell oil off my bucket list I want that
art galleries off my bucket list
and the things that were like all my
bucket lists but things like I'd be like
even though you saw it in the book one
day I'm gonna do with diabetes Network
I'm gonna do something that's just about
diabetes
I did it yeah it's not [ __ ] this you
know what I'm saying
one of the things on my bucket list is
the only football team one of my things
on my bucket list is to have a network
you know a real channel to have a hotel
so there's always like a chapter of my
life where I attack that bucket list one
of the things are not bucket list is to
go lay it you can stay was saying and to
be able to have a farm I would try to go
in make the clothes in the car in the
department that's what we were trying to
do in North Carolina
tell me what influenced you to be the
genius that you are today for like in
like 91 around the 90s early 80s you
know crack came out and it made a lot of
young people without bills money in
their pocket you know and they're like
he became like a young version of a man
and you know I got burned out because I
was one to have the nicest clothes and
the nicest car and you know on Linux
everyone was getting it you know and
that was normal you know it wasn't
normal to not be getting money you know
I'm saying it was like you if he wasn't
getting money he was wait you know I'm
saying he was like you know Lane so you
learn the hustle
yeah and in that you know unconsciously
you know your marketing so like if
you're putting a color on it on your
drug you know and your cat that's
branding and you'll fight because you
don't want anybody to ever compromise
your brand and pretend that they're you
and they give that work you know and
then you have to have that's when
problems happen so you fight with all
you got so that your brand and the
integrity of your brand is always
maintained and there's a lot of
competition so you got to be outside you
know and once you hit the street and
you're dealing with stick-up kids and
the police and you're dealing with math
you know the thing about like drugs is
the prices go up and down every day like
stocks it's like that and then you have
to you know currency you have to you
spend your money as an independent and
then you put all your money in the
street you got cash flow you collect
your money it doubles then you go buy
more like keep a low you know and so on
and so forth so once you understand the
principles of flipping because that's
what it's called and also you're in a
position where like there aren't the
police and people trying to kill you
over it you know things become
relatively easy you know
saying but um the ability to hustle and
get money that definitely happened on
Linux raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that we believe
that people your passion can change the
way people now one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's supposed to mean
if you want more damn - check of the
video are made on how to become your own
boss the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there people
think it's safe to have a job but if
somebody can find you how is that safe
period like you gotta be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you